over the weekend there was a massive
drawdown in bitcoin cryptocurrency
prices what the hell is going on bitcoin
went down more than 20
yes 20 in a single weekend and
previously it hit a haul a high of 69
000
nice of course bitcoin going to 69 000
there's a joke in there somewhere it
then drew all the way down on some
exchanges went below 40 000 most
exchanges around 42 000
and today sits about 48 000 this baby is
very volatile obviously in us dollar
terms but what we can see is why exactly
did this happen sam over at alameda had
a great tweet storm on this he said a
few features of this move were important
the price of bitcoin for instance was
nearing in on a long time local minimum
sub 53k hadn't happened since early
october the same day it cost fifty
thousand dollars it was late friday u.s
early weekend asia among the lowest
liquidity times the entire week he then
went on and said these line up for our
favorite effect liquidations cascades
tons of leveraged longs have been opened
in the past month nothing special just
what always happened in crypto in fact
the insane leverage is lower than it
used to be but the effect was still
substantial then he said part of the
reason it was still substantial was the
low liquidity on various exchanges
bitcoin got sub 30k for a moment and
that was because of how little liquidity
sits on the book during super off hours
the initial liquidations were the same
sizes as usual and then he finished with
but the bids they were getting market
ordered into were thinner because more
price impact and more liquidation since
the prices got really low in many cases
so what you can understand here is if
you don't understand how leverage works
is that people basically saw that there
was consolidation in the 50 000 uh area
for the price 53 54 55 000 per bitcoin a
bunch of people started to take out
leverage they wanted to go along with
leverage they thought the price was
going to go up and at the exact same
time there was tons of leverage in the
system then we also saw that somebody
went on to the order books and when
there was very thin liquidity in when it
was late friday uh night in the united
states and early weekend in asia they
went ahead and they were able to cause a
liquidation cascade basically the way
this works is that if you have leverage
and the price moves against you you then
are a force seller as you sell your
bitcoin the price continues lower then
the next person who's got leverage they
have to sell more and so in a very over
generalized way again very
overgeneralized manner the more people
that are levered long when the price
moves against them the faster and faster
the price goes down which is exactly
what we saw happen here
now as we saw december 4th at 12 33 a.m
this was in the heart of it will
clemente young wizard 1.79 billion
dollars of bitcoin long's liquidated in
the last hour so pretty incredible
amount of leverage getting wiped out in
a very swift move from bitcoin now when
we go ahead and we look we have a quote
from matt malley the equity strategist
at miller tavik he said quote it looks
like somebody likely got hit with a
margin call yesterday and thus was
forced to sell the bitcoin market tends
to be much more thin on the weekend so
that probably exasperated the decline
once the dust has settled the buyer came
back in and it stabilized pretty simple
lots of leverage price moves against you
four sellers price goes down quickly but
we've come back a little bit now where's
bitcoin headed from here we've got ed
moya the senior market analyst at onanda
he said bitcoin is in no man's land
right now and that does not seem to be
changing anytime soon the long-term
bullish case remains remains intact but
prices seem poised to consolidate
between fifty two thousand and sixty
thousand dollars so it's pretty crazy to
see people on wall street now all
talking about bitcoin as a tradable and
investable asset saying that the
long-term bullish case remains intact
but prices seem ready to consolidate one
when you guys woke up on saturday and
saw that the price had dropped
significantly what was your first
reaction well that was the day i was
gonna propose and i was not very happy
i was like damn today's the day y'all
gonna do this
uh but yeah i mean i i saw it and i
disappointing but you can obviously see
what's happening with the leverage and
everything like that so it's not totally
surprising i think some of this stuff
was to be expected once we saw people
kind of the amount of leverage they were
using and the prices that we were seeing
and they're right about kind of uh the
market being thin on the weekends and
then bouncing back up i i'd be more
curious like what is your overall
thought on on retail people using
leverage in general
again i think leverage uh i think i
actually uh tweeted it on saturday
morning when i woke up i just said
leverage is a hell of a drug right and
that's my general uh sense about it is
just like any drug uh leverage uh can be
used to get high on right and it also
can be used to spiral out of control as
well so there's a lot of people who
forget that alcohol is a drug and if i
was to ask most people hey do you like
alcohol they're like yeah i love alcohol
i like the taste of it i like how i feel
when i drink i have fun when i'm
drinking et cetera that's great but in
uh kind of a
average amount drinking alcohol maybe
it's a little bit bad for you but
there's a trade-off because you enjoy
yourself or whatever and there's great
social uh kind of implications to it so
you're willing to drink because you
enjoy it but if you are a drunk 24 7 365
and you overdo it then you could die
right and so like the same thing with
leverage is that if you want to use a
little bit of leverage here and there
one you should know what you're doing if
you can't describe exactly how leverage
works if you don't do it uh and have any
experience like you probably shouldn't
do it right but also too is too much of
it can be deadly it can be fatal right
you can literally lose your entire
portfolio if you become over leveraged
and so i don't think of leverage as good
or bad like in a binary sense i think of
it in terms of how much leverage are you
using and how experienced are you in
using this so if you have no experience
then you probably shouldn't do it right
and also if you're experienced you're
unlikely to go super over levered uh but
still you know market is the market
economic incentives take over people are
greedy and we get highly leveraged
situations because they have high degree
of certainty that price is going higher
and then you get these moves this is
like a like the mo of bitcoin bitcoin
loves to wipe out levered longs like
this and so guess what you know what i
do i literally just stack sats and i
just keep stacking and stacking and
stacking and we'll see what happens
john what do you think
nothing new for bitcoin volatility it
works both ways the levered part of it
some apps like robinhood for example
when you do calls or puts as a retail
trader i believe you have to actually
deposit the amount of money that you
could get um you could have to pay right
so they kind of stopped that from going
way outside your spectrum but almost
incurring a lot of debt which i actually
do like because it stops those retail
traders from getting involved in that um
i saw this on friday night will's of
beast for tweeting this at 12 30 a.m
crypto market does not sleep right 24 7
365 days a year
wall street would not be able to keep up
with this in my opinion um and look yeah
it's nothing new volatility down 20 from
uh friday's closed and kind of had that
draw down into saturday and then we were
as of this morning 10 from friday's
close we were down
it's not uh well it's not concerning but
it also makes you think don't check the
price too much yeah and i was just going
to say right anyone that uh is buying
bitcoin for the day-to-day movements
trying to make money like if that's your
game and you're good at it sure go for
it but i think myself for sure and other
people a lot of other people uh watching
this show do it because they have a long
time horizon right which is the greatest
advantage you can find of saying hey i'm
not going to care about the the
short-term price for the next five years
10 years whatever it might be you're
putting in money that you're hoping uh
you believe in the asset you believe in
the technology believe in the future of
it right so you're saying hey this will
appreciate dramatically in five 10 15
years i'm not going to worry about the
day-to-day movements because when you
look at bitcoin's price historically
everyone knows yes it's been volatile
yes it has appreciated greatly over the
last decade but ultimately even in these
massive run-ups we've seen massive
drawdowns so in 2017 i believe the
number was four to five times during
that bull run uh when it went from about
000 to 20 000 we saw drawdowns of 30 or
more four times right so this is not
anything new from a uh end of the bull
run cycle like we don't necessarily know
what that means i think that this is
more common than people would assume
based off of kind of historical price
movements but ultimately like i said
like if you can just zoom out for a
minute and not care about hey what's
happening every day and just turn the
computer off don't look at the price
don't do all that kind of stuff history
has proven that you're going to be much
better off than kind of worrying about
that day-to-day movement panic selling
getting emotional about things and it's
much better to just have a long time
horizon
over the weekend it was the sixth time
bitcoin went down more than 20
it was the third time that bitcoin went
down more than 30 this current drawdown
right and depending on what the exchange
you looked at in some cases it went down
more than 40 percent it would be the
second time it did that and remember
over the summer there was a 50 plus
drawdown so
volatility is literally the name of the
game when it comes to bitcoin just chill
out does everyone just relax